Since Lost ended, the former cast members
have taken their careers in a variety of different
directions.
But where is Emilie de Ravin?
Well, here’s what happened to the actress
who played Claire on Lost.
Just before the final season of Lost wrapped
up, de Ravin starred in her biggest film role
to date as Robert Pattinson's love interest
in Remember Me.
De Ravin told The Independent that while there
were no off-screen sparks between them, their
on-screen chemistry was the result of a lot
of hard work.
"We spent a lot of time together, talking
about our characters and their relationship,
because it's so important to be comfortable
together.
Then, when we were actually shooting, everything
fell into place and felt natural.
It didn't ever feel like we were reading a
scene or going through the motions."
However, de Ravin also said that it was difficult
to establish that rapport due to the legions
of Twilight fans that plagued the shoot.
"It was difficult for Rob and I to figure
out the logistics of a rehearsal when you've
got thousands of people watching.
Even if you're not looking at them, you're
aware of it.
It can be hard to focus."
Unfortunately, after Remember Me, de Ravin
appeared in a string of movies that just never
seemed to appeal to critics or audiences.
The Chameleon got terrible reviews, Operation:
Endgame only got a limited release in the
United States, and Love and Other Troubles
was filmed mostly in Finnish.
De Ravin's most recent role in a feature film
was in the indie movie The Submarine Kid.
Though her performance was considered a bright
spot, it too fell flat with critics.
Still, de Ravin told Film Monthly she's happy
doing smaller films instead of chasing big
time Hollywood stardom.
"I love the indie circuit.
I think there's some amazing sort of younger
or undiscovered talent out there as far as
directors, and just really edgy scripts.
They're maybe not going to be as widely released
but just really, really interesting subject
matter which definitely interests me."
Lost was a cultural phenomenon, so when the
show ended, many assumed the stars would go
on to even bigger things.
Yet, instead, many of them initially struggled.
Matthew Fox's attempts to become a movie star
fizzled, for instance, while Josh Holloway
had several projects fail.
It got to the point where some pundits joked
there was a "Lost Curse."
And de Ravin wasn't immune: her next project,
Americana, was passed over during pilot season.
Part of the issue may have been that de Ravin
was typecast.
Prior to playing the pregnant Claire on Lost,
she also played a pregnant girl in the film
Brick, and went on to play another pregnant
character in the series Roswell.
She told GQ,
"I must have some sort of maternal draw to
me.
I do love children, but I don't really talk
about that in auditions.
Hi!
I really love kids!
Book me!
But I keep reading scripts that are like that,
too."
It's only fitting that de Ravin eventually
turned to fairy tales to break the curse.
In 2012, de Ravin joined the cast of Once
Upon a Time, which was created by Lost writers
Edward Kitsis and Adam Horowitz.
She played Belle for seven seasons on the
hit show which is even longer than she played
Claire on Lost.
"It's actually quite fabulous how, as I'm
sure you know, they sort of twist around these
fairy tale characters."
She told The Hollywood Reporter,
"It was just a really awesome journey to be
able to give my own spin on such a special,
iconic character and to work with such amazing
people."
De Ravin originally hails from Australia...
I'm the only Australian who loves peanut butter."
...which led to a lot of homesickness early
in her career.
She told The Independent,
"I don't get home as much as I would like
to.
I miss my family so much, my ideal holiday
is just to hang out with them."
Now, though, she has her own family in America.
After divorcing her first husband, actor Josh
Janowicz, in 2014, de Ravin fell in love with
The Submarine Kid writer and director Eric
Bilitch.
They got engaged in 2016, the same year de
Ravin gave birth to their daughter Vera.
And in 2018, de Ravin celebrated two new milestones:
she gave birth to their son, Theodore, and
she officially became a U.S. citizen.
You know what they say: home is where the
heart is.
In 2017, de Ravin told Entertainment Weekly
that she was finally taking some time off
of work to focus on her new family.
"There are things in the works right now,
but I've taken the last few months off to
be a mom, because I've been working since
I had my daughter a year and a half ago, so
I was just very excited to be able to do that."
Since then, she's been true to her word, with
her only recent project being the 2019 TV
movie A Lover Scorned.
It looks like this phase of her career will
be all about finding a balance between work
and family, but with two successful shows
and few solid films under her belt, de Ravin
still has a bright future in Hollywood if
and when she wants it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.